un panneau installé à l'entrée de la
commune qui en dit long sur l'ambiance
qui règne actuellement à crimolois en
mars dernier l'annnonce du maire de
créer une commune nouvelle avec
neuilly-lès-dijon a surpris tout le
monde à commencer par les conseillers
municipaux eux mêmes en tant que
conseiller j'ai une autre idée de mon
rôle c'est à dire de préparer des
projets d'un jeune femme la population
et qu'ensemble on essaie de voir ce qui
est de l'intérêt de notre commune peut
plutôt que d'être interpellé un jour
comme ça sans savoir de quoi il s'agit
et me dire que on va s'engager dans ce
que j'appellerais pour l'instant une
aventure inconnue
le projet suscite l'inquiétude de
certains habitants de crimolois site
internet tracts banderoles
il communique à tout va ils craignent de
voir neuilly qui est deux fois plus
peuplée et favoriser dans ce
regroupement
ils dénoncent également un projet qu'il
destine qutb loin on n'a pas forcément
opposé à la fusion mais ce qu'on
souhaite avoir son des arguments
concrets des chiffres précis puisque
pour l'instant on n'a ni arguments ni
chiffres sur ce que va devenir la
commune et on sait très bien par exemple
que les impôts de neuilly et en plus
élevés que ceux de crimes au loin
forcément et monsieur novotny l'a
déclaré en réunion publique le 22 mai
dernier que les impôts des habitants
crimolois vont augmenter françois
novotny le maire de la commune n'a pas
souhaité participer à notre reportage
par téléphone il nous indique que ce
projet peut permettre d'obtenir de
meilleurs dotations de l'état également
de peser plus au niveau de la métropole
pas convaincu le collectif sauvons
crimolois a lancé une pétition et
revendique 350 signatures